in previous videos you could see us
doing a bunch of different things here
on Project Camp many things are made
this year but now season 2 is coming to
an end we need to wrap up and prepare
for the winter many rainy days are
coming so we need to get ready for that
we're going to fix the plastic roof
repair the door in the waterfall so we
can store water and clean a new well
that we recently found welcome to new
project Camp update
hey so winter is coming and we need to
prepare ourselves a little bit for that
because many people would leave only a
few people would stay here to really
reflect and plan the next year
and so we need to prepare ourselves a
little bit for all the rain that is
coming and a few things we want to do is
want to still get the wood chipper and
chop down a lot of trees we chopped down
before to make sure we can spread them
on the ground so they can absorb all the
moist we want to re-oil our structures
from boot that we made last year to give
them an extra protective layer and we're
going to level a new area where we're
going to put a container for storage
which is going to be very useful to keep
everything dry and we need to break down
the tents where the people were sleeping
because they're not going to be used the
whole winter
so all of these small things are ongoing
are already done actually but we have a
few bigger things to do and one of them
is the plastic roof which was still
leaking needed to fix
Aiden wanted to do it but he got busy
working on the ruin and also the
pressure was off because yeah it was
sunny so no water coming but now with a
lot of rain in the air coming we really
need to fix it so Aiden is going to show
you what we're going to do next with
that so we have this roof made with
recycled plastic sheets by a pressure
plastic workspace as a test but we found
out that the design maybe is not the
best the plastic sheets were up on this
ring because of the heat so we try some
solutions to avoid leaks like
overlapping the sheets and screwing them
to the wooden frame due to the wire pin
the screws broke put in some bottle and
windshield glue on top it's not really a
touching and duct tape
so far nothing worked yet but we still
need a solution for this winter so we're
gonna try something else this is for
chat type
meant to be outside UV protected
waterproof let's hope it reduces longer
[Music]
I love tape
I love it
come on
[Music]
we're gonna make some rain test if it
still leaks what are we doing but making
good making
but there's still a hole in here there
we go look at this
wow
[Music]
out of this book it's not working
we're up on the uh sketchy roof
and no no no we are up on the recycled
plastic roof next to the kitchen here
still some leaks so now we're gonna try
and put it
between this solar panel and the roof
because we think that it could be coming
under like this
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
test and let's see if it works
[Music]
no leak so far there's some water that's
here seems okay
it's not really leaking it's good
[Music]
all right so meanwhile we're waiting for
the ring to come we heard the neighbor
saying there's actually another well on
the land so not the one we use for our
drinking water but another much older
one and we've been trying to find it
together with them but we we could never
really find it but only recently we saw
a few glimpses of it of what we think is
a well so we're going to go down there
now because Julie's going to clean it up
to see what we're going to find
it's going to be down here
it has been already since the year that
we have been clearing up this part of
the one that I'm standing at now
but just recently we found the well on
the other side
let me show you
over here
this is the well quite overgrown a lot
of bushes a lot of mimosa there's not
much water it's just mats on the bottom
floor but we're gonna try to dig a
little bit to see if we can reach the
water table this well is actually made
out of granite it might mean that it's
way older the one we haven't used at the
moment is made out of bricks maybe let
me show you where we actually are we're
next to the puff close to the new ruin
we're on the side of the field where the
yoga deck is under the cork tree we are
quite close to that and this is where
the well is
it was our neighbor Antonio that told us
that there was a well in this area but
as you might have seen is very difficult
to exit
this is the reason why we've never seen
it
we might then also start with the
clearings towards the field to start up
clearing this area but I will not be
able to do this by myself so I'm gonna
add some extra hands
forever
[Music]
that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we're almost there
look look look
we found the well yeah no
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
big dead trees around and trees hanging
over so we're gonna start now with
cutting them down and open it up a
little bit more
thank you
laughs
[Music]
the ladder okay the ladder yeah it's my
deepest
we have a super big leather
yeah it feels really soon
super fluffy no if you could also yeah
it's it's kind of wet down there this is
the first time in the bottom of the well
and there are lots of dead twigs and
branches but it's also very spongy moist
soil
oh
pork
I'm coming up
[Applause]
foreign
so I've been digging down for a little
bit
and we're starting to find water at
least you you look like you want to get
in here yeah one of them okay
[Music]
thank you
all right so the well is now cleaned up
we still have this guy here we didn't
know what to do with it but it looks
kind of cool so yeah let's see we also
added some protection around it to make
sure we don't walk in at night when
someone is sleepwalking
and so now it's basically waiting for
the rain to come so it raises the water
table and then there should be water in
the well let's see but before the rain
comes we have one last thing to do and
you guys commented a lot about this it
was when we cleaned up the waterfall
there was this metal gate that was
completely stuck it's frustrating
because we tried a lot of the
instruments a lot of I don't know but
you guys gave some good comments on how
to make it unstuck so we're gonna give
that a try and see if we can move the
thing because then we can close it for
winter and gather all the rain water
that comes in
so time to go to the waterfowl
all right so here we are at the metal
door still very stuck uh time did pass
by as you can see behind me the plants
are growing but now we want to make sure
we unstuck it because uh is that a word
we want to make sure we can move it
around because when the rain starts to
come we want to close it so the water
here fills up and we have a lagoon we've
got a few good comments from you guys
from the last video with some future
potential Solutions we're going to start
with the most promising one because if
that one works well it would save a lot
of extra work so the one with the most
potential of fixing this problem is
yeah what else ketchup
you know YouTube comments it's not that
I don't trust you but
sometimes I doubt whether all the things
you say are really true
[Music]
so ketchup didn't really work out next
candidate
Cola
right so the cola is in now we'll let it
soup for a few hours and give it a good
smack
let's see if it comes out
so no success with Coke next one
vinegar also going to put this one in
and let it soak for a while
so putting on the ketchup wasn't very
satisfying because it's too thick but
the Coke and the vinegar really goes all
the way into the cracks so you really
feel like it's going in there
but I'm not sure if it's enough
so while we are waiting for the vinegar
to soak in let me show you something
interesting actually one of the reasons
why we tried to open up the gate So
currently it's end of the summer and the
water stream as you can see it here it's
not very big and the water used to flow
much bigger it would hit the rock there
way more sounds as well but that was in
Winter and Springtime now it's at the
end of summer so it was very hot very
dry so almost no water flowing anymore
and this is also the water that goes
down to our Creek but something
interesting is happening there let me
show you
so the water from the waterfall is
Flowing here gradually down there which
is actually our Creek so it starts here
and then it goes all the way to the
bottom of the land and as you can see
the water is just flowing not much but
it's flowing if we continue following
the creek which is right there you can't
really see the creek anymore because
there are way too many bushes and spikes
so in order to see the creek again we
have to walk a little bit more until the
area we cleaned up last year wait let me
actually show this with the Drone so
it's a bit easier for you to understand
where we are so here we have the
waterfall where you see the water
flowing now we just walk this pathway
we're halfway in as you can see it's
very bushy and we can't really see the
creek but if we continue to follow the
line right there we cleaned that up last
year as you can see in the update videos
with our moms so we can go there now to
really see the Greek gun
so here I am now in the creek might be
hard to see but there used to be water
flowing here and but now it hasn't been
flowing for a while so plants started
growing back and this actually used to
be a stream that goes all year round but
this year because it was so dry it just
dried up and uh yeah no more water and
it's kind of strange seeing the water
still flow there from the waterfall even
within Little Creek and then somewhere
between there and here the water just
stops and it goes into the soil imagine
if you're a fish and you go Downstream
and suddenly and it just stops it's kind
of weird thinking about it but anyway
that's one of the reasons why we want to
fix that gate up there so we can close
it down and fill up the Lagoon there
with water in Winter times when a lot of
rain comes and then we have a bit of a
reserve and backup in case it's going to
be very dry in summer times so here we
are after a day of soaking vinegar let's
see if it pops out
still stuck didn't move so we're going
to try the next thing which actually
suggested maybe most by everyone is w40
like a lubricant we already tried this
before but it didn't work but maybe now
after the vinegar and the Coke and stuff
changes
so yeah that didn't really work either
so so next suggestion
hello George
so we tried a bunch of things now I'll
do it with work I actually had high
hopes for uh
heating up that it would crack
so not many options left and up until
now we've been hammering with this one
so next we're gonna try this guy bigger
Hammer didn't really want to use it yet
because it would also warm the metal a
bit more and damage the
concrete around it but running out of
options here
[Music]
um
been hammering for quite a bit now as
you can see the whole sheet starts to
deform
uh so yeah this thing takes a different
shape with absolutely no movement in the
sheet itself
it's impressive running out of options
so
kind of get a bit more drastic
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
ly out it was mainly Rusty here at the
bottom actually pretty stuck still but
now we have this broken door but I
figured maybe we just clean it up and
weld it back together so we can slide it
in so as you have the grinder here I'm
going to clean up these edges and I'm
going to bring this to the workspace and
then fix it up hopefully
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
we have our yellow items painted and
cleaned up ready to go in some bolts and
nuts some screws wrenches hammers to get
it in because we added some paint which
made it a bit thicker and it warped
during the welding so hope it's gonna
still fit in there so yeah let's see
grab this
you're not left-handed but
boy
thank you
feel so good to see it going up and down
let me do it once again
yeah
okay now we have our water get ready we
only need to wait for the rain to come
and fill up the Lagoon quite excited to
see this happen
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
is coming as you might see so now it's
time to close the gate and hopefully
fill up this Lagoon no idea oh this is
gonna go maybe the whole wall is gonna
collapse because it didn't hurt water
for many years
no idea let's see
wait
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Lagoon is now filling up but we have a
few unexpected leaks let me show you
so the door itself is releasing some
water there was a small Gap underneath
but I guess combined with a lot of
fracture on that size makes quite a bit
come out and it's leaking here on the
edges as well as the water goes up I
think still more water is coming in than
out so that's good but yeah some lockers
so here we have the wall and the granite
rock and this Leaf comes from underneath
the rock so we're using the other side
it's really hard to see where it's
actually leaking so this is going to be
a more difficult one to pick and here
the water is leaking through the cracks
of the wall and as you can see it's also
quite a substantial amount but this is
leaking into the irrigation pipes or the
funnels that you might have seen when we
cleaned the waterfall which is quite
cool so this would eventually distribute
itself on the land so kind of curious
actually to see where this is Flowing
too but overall more water is flowing in
than going out so the Lagoon is still
filling up we're now about halfway so
you just have to wait a little bit
longer hopefully nothing collapses along
the way and then
transform a bit this landscape
[Applause]
all right so after some days the Lagoon
is overflowing wow look at that it's
impressive I'm a bit worried about the
walls collapsing the neighbors even
warned us for that but looks awesome
like an infinity pool but better all
natural running on the creek
so now we have a water reservoir that we
can control to use the irrigate the
fields in the dry months or just chill
if it gets too hot in summer probably
mostly used for that
so far very satisfied and I guess we
still need to see how the well actually
is doing with all this rain so let's get
back to Julie okay it has been a couple
of days ago since we have been clearing
up the well and there has been a lot of
rain we're gonna check it out oh it
looks
foreign
okay
I guess this shows how deep the water is
there is still a dirt layer underneath
but
it feels like a good start
what
quite some centimeters
[Music]
as you might have seen the well is quite
cleared up now we have space we will
walk around it thanks to Antonio great
tips we know where it is now but this
means it's quite far from base camp at
the moment we don't really know what
it's going to be used for but we keep an
eye on it during the winter and see what
the water level does
ciao
wait we decided to go a bit further on
the Watergate check it out so here we
are at the bonus round the lake is all
filled up
but we kind of want to see what happens
when we quickly open up this thing just
for the sake of trying so Adrian and me
are gonna do a speed turning
oh well
you will survive
give me a little bit more huh okay but
they're exploding the whole land
[Applause]
foreign
I don't know if we should continue
because it floods everything
's gone the other one man [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
huh you have to find it
here would be the first Dam I guess
[Music]
[Applause]
it was there in the middle
connected to a stick yeah there yeah so
one GoPro flushed away so now it's
somewhere there but there are a lot of
brumbles
but I think we have to walk the creek to
find it
all right so that was it for this video
next week we're gonna finish up the ruin
for this year last video of the Season
should be exciting if you really want to
see that make sure to support us on
patreon so you can see it one week ahead
without advertisement or subscribe and
then you just see it next week here same
channel same time supporting on patreon
also helps a lot because I think we need
to get a new GoPro or if you have a
GoPro 7 laying around let us know we
would be very happy with it if you don't
use it anymore
thanks for watching see you next week